[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're going
to be breaking down Oppenheimer in the
movie we follow the father of the atomic
bomb and watch as he develops a
world-changing weapon throughout the
story he's pitted against two people and
this comes in the form of a German
scientist and also a U.S Secretary in
the movie we learn that both don't get
their way and you might have some
questions about what happens to them
next throughout this video we're going
to be going through both Strauss and
Heisenberg's Legacy and what happened to
them after the events of the film heavy
spoilers ahead so if you haven't seen
the movie yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now I know most of
this is involving history but there's
people who don't know the ins and outs
of it and I think that people should see
the film first anyway without the way if
you're still here thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of Oppenheimer
so early in the movie we meet Verna
Heisenberg who becomes somewhat of a
rival to Robert Oppenheimer the movie
only really shows things from the
titular character's perspective and this
is why we never encounter Heisenberg
during the war now as we see he was a
highly renowned scientist and he was
actually the winner of a Nobel Prize the
scientists published a paper that
changed how we look at physics and this
was known as the uncertainty principle
the Nobel Prize was given during 1932
and the air after saw the Nazis gaining
power they dismissed several scientists
simply for being Jewish and people like
Einstein ended up being the country
Heisenberg was also the victim of
ideological attacks and he was labeled
as a white Jew in the press and papers
now this is someone who was wide but
someone who was said to be fascinated
with Jewish cultural movements at the
time Boren Einstein was seen as
prominent figures but even their studies
were labeled as Jewish signs
investigated by the SS for yeah he was
somewhat saved by his mother who
happened to be a friend of Heinrich
himmel's family this allowed him to
continue working as a scientist and he
traveled through the U.S studying
nuclear fission a Heisenberg actually
never even considered fleeing his
country even though he was offered
teaching appointments out in the U.S
it's said that he was devoutly loyal to
Germany and he completely refused to
turn against his homeland you have to
remember that Heisenberg grew up in a
time in which his country was reeling
from the loss of the first world war
there was a great sense in building the
country back up and thus he refused to
turn his back on it he'd already seen
what the world had done to Germany and
he ended up pledging his allegiances to
Adolf Hitler the Heisenberg was selected
by the Germans to build their atomic
bomb and this song being drafted into
the army weapons Bureau he had an almost
two-year Head Start in the western
allies but critical mistakes delayed all
of his research at one point Heisenberg
destroyed the lab creating a reaction
and this set back the bomb development
by an Untold amount focusing primarily
on hardwood air this caused the
experiments to be even more dangerous
and the water boiled before 10 turning
into a fire that then torched the lab we
will talk about how this was something
that redeemed Heisenberg later on but
there were several mistakes that caused
his efforts to be unsuccessful there's
also the fact that Hitler didn't trust
all of his scientists unless he withheld
funding and resources whereas the US
didn't in the movie they talk about how
the Manhattan Project cost 2 billion
which if you think about inflation would
be whatever this number on screen is
right now that I can't even say now
being such a high value Target this also
put him in the crosshairs of both the
allies and Nazis summoned to bill in
because of the destruction of his lab he
begged for more time to continue his
work Heisenberg then went out a lecture
in Switzerland which during the war was
standing as a neutral country Eisenberg
was due to give a lecture and it was at
this time that America made their play
now the CIA wasn't a thing at the time
but they still had Black Op agents
working in the field sending in an
assassin known as moberg they had him
attend a lecture to try and see whether
Heisenberg was making Headway milberg
was ordered to kill him if he then
they'd got to that point and he sat in
the lectures listening to any little
clue Berg was listening intensely for
any little hint and that night he
apparently ended up following him now
according to the stories Heisenberg
mistakenly thought he was SS and said
that if they wanted the bomb they'd just
have to back off this confirmed to Berg
that they hadn't ended up developing it
and because of this he never pulled the
trigger after this time Heisenberg made
extremely little progress and to make
matters worse Germany were badly losing
the war Germany was being invaded on all
sides and this led to the capture of
Heisenberg and all the other scientists
this happened on May 3rd 1945 but he was
declared as an asset due to being one of
Germany's top scientists escorted a farm
Hall in England he was put in her
interrogation which is when they learned
how far the Germans were actually behind
the progress I'd made over years had
been made in months in America and they
were deemed as being years away from
actually making the bomb now while this
was going on the Trinity test was
carried out and this happened in July of
the same year as we know atomic bombs
ended up being dropped into targets
ending the war after Japan's surrender
Heisenberg was shocked believing there
was no way they could actually build a
bomb because he'd failed in all of his
attempts Heisenberg was never put on
trial for working alongside the Nazis
and he was instead allowed to go back to
Germany from here he moved out to
America which is when he built the math
Empire along his ex-student known as
Jesse Pinkman
[Music]
foreign
1946 he resumed his directorship at The
Institute for physics and became a
spokesman for peaceful science he was
seen as someone that was a valuable
asset for rebuilding the country and he
would state that he intentionally
sabotaged his work with the Nazis this
of course has been contested but he
remains strong in the stance that he
deliberately didn't want the bomb to
work kinda like that bit in the office
where they asked David Brent if he
somehow faked medical signs so that the
rest of his team wouldn't face
redundancies and in the end it can't
really be disproven however I think it's
actually an important thing to talk
about as it kind of shows the opposite
reactions that Oppenheimer faced both
were people who said that we should be
careful building bombs but Opie was
persecuted by his own government and
stripped of his clearance on the other
side of this Heisenberg was seen as the
voice of reason and because of this he
was paraded throughout his post-war
years he became the first president of
the German research Council and was
instrumental in the European Council for
nuclear research during the 50s he
became the founding president of the
Humboldt Foundation before publishing an
autobiography in 1969 he pivoted
slightly into talking about philosophy
and was widely regarded as a fountain of
wisdom in his final years Heisenberg
contracted kidney cancer and he died in
his home on the 1st of February 1976 the
next night his friends lit up a candle
and placed it on his front door in
remembrance to him now that pretty much
covers most of his career and post-war
workings and we next move over to Louis
stross I'm not gonna go over all the
internets of his career as semia gets
touched upon more in depth in the movie
but Heisenberg we don't really get any
of that so for the next part of the
video I promise it won't be as boring
what do you mean you actually enjoyed it
now the weather the timeline works in
the film might confuse you a bit as I
jump about with events during and after
the war the humiliation of Strauss
actually happened during 1949 making it
four years after the end of the second
world war Ramirez Strauss started
putting plans in place and this was to
have oppenheimer's secure 30 clearance
completely revoked the clothes hearing
for this happened in 1945 and it would
then be another five years for us to get
a hearing that we see playing out
publicly 1959 saw straw spelling to gain
an appointment as Secretary of Commerce
after his bias against Oppenheimer was
brought out into the open this rocked
him a bit because it was one of the only
times in U.S history that a cabinet
appointee failed to be given
confirmation he had been nominated by
President Eisenhower and this came as a
blight that never really left him this
led to stress in retiring which
completely ended his career though he
did stay close friends with President
Eisenhower now though he is often
portrayed as the villain there are those
that came to his defense during the
aftermath of it either way Strauss died
in 1974 at the beginning of the air on
January 21st this was at his home on the
Brandy Rock farm with his funeral being
held out in New York and that concludes
our video on the pair and I hope this
has helped you to add some context to
the movie I definitely think it's worth
looking at both characters as to me in
the film they reflect Oppenheimer the
best we have his opponent out in Germany
who's a match for a man or to those
within his homeland working directly
against him it paints out a complex in
nuanced history and I hope that you've
enjoyed going back to it all with us if
you have then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe of
videos like this every day you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please consider
also clicking the join button you'll get
early access to videos every single week
and it costs less than a magnum I slot
he did back in the 90s now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
video on Oppenheimer on screen right now
so definitely head over there right
after this lots of things to talk about
in the film and if you've got anything
else you want to see me cover then yeah
make sure you drop it below by the way
I've been your host Paul you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace